SPEAKER: Welcome to
this episode of Click
to Deploy, a series
where we show you
how easy it is to deploy
solutions from the Google Cloud
marketplace.
In this episode,
we'll be reviewing
how to set up NetApp Cloud
Volumes ONTAP via the Cloud
Marketplace.
NetApp Cloud Volumes
ONTAP in Google Cloud
is a data management layer that
runs natively on Google Cloud
infrastructure, enabling
enhanced control,
data protection,
mobility, and agility
for business application data.
Let's start by searching
for a Cloud Volumes
ONTAP in the Google
Cloud marketplace.
For this demo, we'll choose
the solution Cloud Manager
for Cloud Volumes ONTAP.
The landing page will
display information
about the solution, pricing,
documentation, and support.
To use Cloud Manager
and Cloud Volumes ONTAP,
Google Cloud users
need to subscribe
to Cloud Volumes ONTAP via
the Google Cloud marketplace.
Let's click the Subscribe
button to launch the solution.
Start first by choosing
a billing account
and agreeing to the
terms below, which
are terms about subscription
fee billed monthly
and canceling the service.
After choosing the
Subscribe button,
you will see a notification
to register with NetApp, Inc.
Before we visit
NetApp, let's make
sure to create a
Google Cloud account
with the necessary Identity and
Access Management, IAM, policy.
This will make it
possible to use
Cloud Manager with your
Google Cloud environment.
From this NetApp
website, download
the connector deployment
policy for GCP
and the Cloud Manager
policy for GCP.
Let's create a custom role
for the connector deployment
and assign it to a user.
In the Cloud Shell,
upload the setup
as service version
GCP YAML permission
file you previously downloaded.
For the Cloud Shell,
use this command
to create a custom role for
the file at the organization
or project level.
We'll make this role
at the project level.
The role created using
the permission file
will be titled
NetApp Cloud central.
To grant the new role
created to the relevant user,
you can run the gcloud
addiam-policy-binding command.
Next, let's set up
a service account
that will be associated
with the connector VM.
Start by uploading policy
for Cloud Manager version
gcp.yaml permission
file to the Cloud Shell.
Then go to IAM & Admin,
Navigate to Service
Account, then
Create a New Service Account.
For Service Account Name,
choose NetApp Connector.
For Role, choose
NetApp Cloud Central.
Now, we have a Google Cloud user
with the permissions required
to create a connector
from Cloud Manager,
as well as a service account
for the connector VM.
Let's enable Cloud API
needed for Cloud Volumes.
Go to API & Services tab.
We'll need to make sure the
following APIs are enabled--
Cloud Deployment Manager
V2 API, Cloud Logging API,
Cloud Resource Manager API,
Compute Engine API, Identity
and Access Management, IAM API.
Now, let's deploy NetApp.
First, go to the Marketplace
Cloud Volumes landing page
and choose Manage on Provider.
Create an account or log in
to your existing account.
Next, we'll navigate
to Fabric View
and choose Cloud Volumes ONTAP.
Go to Cloud Manager.
Let's add our first
working environment.
First, we'll choose
Google Cloud platform.
Next, we'll choose
Cloud Volumes ONTAP.
Now, let's create
a connector which
allows Cloud Manager to
manage resources and processes
within your public
cloud environment.
We'll choose Google
Cloud Platform.
We will need to
provide permissions
to connect our Google
account with Cloud Manager.
We'll set our Connector
Instance Name.
Let's use test-connector.
We'll set the project.
It will be connected
to test-ctd.
We'll set Surface
Account NetApp Connector.
Next, we'll set the
Location details.
I'll keep the defaults.
Then we'll set the Connectivity
to Public IP Enable.
And finally, for the firewall
policy, choose My IP.
Now that we filled out all of
this additional information,
make sure to review the details.
As you can see, the connector
was successfully created.
Congratulations on successfully
deploying a NetApp Cloud
Volumes ONTAP instance.
You now have a
platform to simplify
the management of your
workloads on Google Cloud.
If you enjoyed this video,
please subscribe and hit
the Like button below.
We encourage you to check out
the Google Cloud marketplace
and deploy the
solution on your own.
Thanks for watching.